dans cette salle de production
une odeur de citronnelle melia celle de
la noix de coco
voilà c'est pour obtenir un mélange
totalement homogène dont vingt fois
j'avais le lait de coco et dans l'autre
partie j'avais ma préparation parce
qu'elle a prévu de réaliser deux parfums
de glace d'abord la citronnelle infuser
puis transformé en sirop et pour cette
préparation il utilise différents sucres
c'est là le secret d'une glace équilibre
et qu'on n'est pas sur un mix général
opel on va rajouter un peu de citron un
peu de groseille n'en pas douter ou si
chaque parfum c'est une recette des
recettes tirées de son vieux grimoire
pour le reste les jets sont mécaniques
après cuisson il t'a cerise il turbine
et la voici glace et la version finale
sur la glace d'excellence chaque glace à
son histoire six mois chaque sort des
fonds afin d'y croire l'idée d'un parfum
peut arriver à n'importe quel moment
lorsqu'on est passionné par son métier
changements de température ici
l'atmosphère est plutôt chaleureuse
temps médiévaux janin ses clients
apprécient ses classes et savent le
démontrer au chocolat au chocolat
coco passion merveilleux elle est super
bonne je n'ai pas eu le dernier mot et
puis tu as voyagé l'année atteint le 18
février pour arranger avec le travail il
ya le relationnel qui s'installe puisque
les clients ils se sentent en confiance
ils savent que quand ils y feront appel
excellence glace qui ne seront pas déçus
des relations toujours très bien
entretenu surtout avec sa plus grande
clientèle
ce succès lui a ouvert les portes du
salon de l'agriculture à paris en france
plus d'un demi million de visiteurs
pourrait se laisser séduire par les
classes de pascal on saveurs d'ici et
d'ailleurs